joining us now are former white house
chiefs of staff reince priebus and mark
meadows along with former arkansas
governor
mike huckabee is with us uh mark meadows
we begin with you
you were in the room you were there
as reince priebus was with conversations
with president xi
what is the difference between what
you're reading and seeing now
and what it was like when donald trump
was president
well it's a position of weakness you you
mentioned it in your monologue sean but
really there's two words that uh
define this this presidency right now
one is weakness the other is desperation
they're desperate to do anything to take
uh the the focus off of joe biden's
in-app policies that continue to haunt
the american people listen whether it's
china and you've been one of the few
that have been consistently talking
about the debacle in afghanistan that
caused cost 13 american service members
their lives but candidly it's that
weakness that goes all the way through
joe biden has a knock on wood kind of
strategy and hope for the best and it is
not giving americans the best
reince you were there when i think you
were there when when president trump
actually had president xi at the white
house am i wrong on that
well actually i can answer this i was at
the meeting in mar-a-lago when president
xi came to mar-a-lago and we were having
dinner i sat across the table from
president xi and i was sitting next to
president trump
and there were i one thing remarkable
about this dinner that there were two
topics
that president xi went on 30 minutes
straight without stopping on number one
was the history of china and japan and
number two was taiwan and president xi
went on and on and on
about the strategic importance of taiwan
making it clear they didn't want us
messing with taiwan president trump
after dinner said excuse me i have an
emergency i'll be right back
left the dinner table
went down to a private room
authorized the launch of 59 cruise
missiles into syria came back
sat down and said oh we just launched 59
cruise missiles into syria how's the
creme brulee that's the difference
between joe biden and donald trump
uh
my
i've actually heard that story so i know
that for a fact that that's true that's
been confirmed by a lot of people
governor huckabee i mean these are
simple but yet deeply profound
principles it's called peace but only
peace through strength not weakness uh
to me if you look at all the hostile
regimes around the world they sense
weakness and they're all taking
advantage of it
we've all seen this movie before it's
called back to the future joe biden is
george mcfly
and biff is getting the best of him
every time
and it's just really something that we
need to recognize is a real danger not
just to the u.s but it's a danger to the
whole free world because these dictators
and totalitarians really see an
opportunity they see an opening they've
watched what happens with biden they
know that he's compromised in terms of
how many business deals that his son and
probably he has had with china
and china's just running with it and uh
it really should be
a major concern to members of congress i
for one i'm glad nancy pelosi went to
taiwan i'm glad somebody is saying to
china we'll do what we dog on well want
to we don't take orders from you and i
wish biden had stood with her and just
for the record you're not going to hear
me very often say these kind of nice
things about nancy pelosi but on this
week
she did governor she didn't have a
choice once that threatened
out of the sky my view she didn't have a
choice
um
she did i don't think mark meadows i
don't see
any scenario under which
what china's saying or calling
reunification with taiwan doesn't take
place and frankly i don't see a solution
to getting brittany griner home that's
an american citizen that does not belong
in jail for nine years and and offering
this master of death in exchange
you couldn't have a more one-sided deal
in favor of putin and putin's still
rejecting it
well he's still rejecting it but again
it goes back to the theme it's the
weakness that you didn't see under
donald trump and you're seeing each and
every day and you're right uh listen
when they smell weakness what happens it
it makes uh leaders like she and putin a
lot more aggressive and we continue to
see it you know a nine year sentence uh
for miss greiner it's it's sad we want
her to come home but now we're training
uh her for a prisoner that actually was
convicted of conspiracy who killed
american citizens you know it sets a
very bad precedent i can tell you uh
donald trump when he was in the white
house was able to get more hostages
released and back home without having to
kind of pay the price why because the
leaders knew he was strong and he was
willing to back it up you know let's
stay on that theme reince priebus
because this is the difference here
whether remember the taliban didn't kill
an american for the last 18 months of
trump's presidency um we we didn't see
north korea just
all donald trump ever gave kim jong-un
was a little bit of time that's it and
we got a lot of concessions on on from
north korea as a result uh you didn't
see these hostilities from russia or
china so what's the difference here is
it is it is it that they see weakness
and they're going to take advantage of
it
well albert einstein had a famous quote
that that weakness of attitude is
weakness of character and so when you
start on day one destroying your border
making your country not energy
independent again when you allow
countries
that you quoted the second half of
reagan's quote to peace through strength
and weakness invites aggression and and
it's true and so it started on day one
it continued to afghanistan through the
economy to gas to fuel energy
independence and now he's desperate on
this brittany grinder issue and by the
way the other piece of this the fact
that that
that joe biden was upstaged by his own
speaker and a speaker didn't listen to
joe biden
yet again within his own party now
they're walking away from him on 2024
it's weakness all the way from day one
and now his own parties abandoning him
do you see any scenario mike huckabee
under which
joe biden would shock us all and stand
up to russia or china because i do not
no i i don't see it we're not seeing it
he's been in office now for going on two
years and he certainly hasn't given that
kind of impression and uh if he's gonna
do it there never has been a better time
than this week and he's failed to do it
and why i don't know and and john kirby
can defend him all he wants to
but to say that joe biden was so busy he
didn't have opportunity or time to pick
up the phone and to say something to to
chi is just it's absurd it is utterly
absurd what was he doing ordering ice
cream for takeout i mean
what's more important than trying to
keep china from invading and taking over
taiwan right now
yeah all right thank you all very smart
scary scenarios unfolding hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else